bien merci chers collègues Monsieur le
Préfet
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation pour
échanger sur la
question importante de l'eau comme vous
le savez donc nous avons fait une
mission transpartisane sur la gestion
durable de l'eau qui était lancée en
février à la demande du groupe
socialiste
dans le cadre du droit de tirage que
vous connaissez des groupes
et donc elle comprend l'ensemble des
groupes politiques et son rapporteur et
donc mon collègue Hervé Gillet
sénateur de giron que vous connaissez
certainement parce qu'il a aussi
beaucoup agi dans le domaine de l'eau
dans ce département et on a donc débuté
les les auditions la semaine dernière
par les agences de l'eau
et je suis ensuite on souhaitait donc
vous entendre vous en tant qu'en qualité
de Délégué interministériel au Varennes
agricoles de l'eau qui a eu lieu cette
année où la dernière
et je voulais simplement vous dire que
le l'audition fait l'objet d'un
compte-rendu officiel auquel chacun
pourra se référer donc voir qu'il est
enregistré
il sera peut-être sur internet je sais
pas si c'est
donc en rappelant que pour ce que vous
connaissez l'eau et bien évidemment
essentiel pour l'activité agricole et on
voit bien que
2022 était très difficile et que 2023
s'annonce peut-être encore plus
difficile compte tenu de la plus
vométrique nous avons même si il pleut
un petit peu en ce moment mais ça va pas
être suffisant pour recharger les nappes
et donc le changement climatique mais à
mal un peu tout des territoires tous nos
producteurs
et puis l'objectif c'est que on puisse
échanger avec vous
on a rencontré
au salon de l'école d'agriculture mais à
certains membres de professionnels de
l'eau qui sont inquiets sur le devenir
de cette année sur les volumes quel que
soit les filières d'ailleurs
et donc le varen de agricole que vous
avez donc mené de l'eau fait le pari
qu'on peut parvenir à une gestion
apaisée
et j'espère équilibrer et puis efficace
de l'eau pour nous agriculteurs en
mobilisant tous les leviers que ce soit
d'abord la sobriété
la résilience est plus en constituant
aussi une nouvelle réserve parce que
si on veut avoir une eau constante et
qu'on évite de pomper dans la nappe au
moment de l'étiage des rivières je pense
que les réserves de substitution nous
paraissent encore de bonne aloi et on
voit malheureusement que la mise en
oeuvre de la gestion sur le terrain pour
ses réserves et compliquées donc merci
de et je vais laisser la parole à mon
collègue avec gilet qui va vous poser un
certain nombre de questions mais on
compte sur vous pour nous éclairer dans
tout ce domaine merci à vous
bien merci monsieur le Président Cherry
bonjour à vous tous à vous tous je
remercie aussi mes collègues pour leur
présence et vous remercie monsieur le
Préfet Monsieur le Délégué
interministériel pour votre
disponibilité
cette mission d'information dans un
contexte un peu concret contraint au
niveau des agendas
nous a permis déjà d'ouvrir un certain
nombre de sujets que nous souhaitons
approfondir bien évidemment vous avez eu
communication des questions que nous
souhaitions
approfondir avec vous
mais peut-être quelques éclairages
particuliers sur lequel nous avons des
attentes peut-être plus spécifiques
notamment au travers du travail qui a
été fait pour recenser et faire un
inventaire de toutes les ressources qui
sont aujourd'hui disponibles et
notamment un certain nombre de réserves
qui pourraient être je parle bien sûr au
conditionnel mobilisables à un moment
donné une des questions qui se pose
aussi derrière
ce recensement qui
laisse apparaître des potentiels
intéressants c'est aussi les conflits
éventuellement juridiques qu'il peut y
avoir un certain nombre de réserves sont
évidemment privés aujourd'hui
donc se pose la question de la capacité
de leur réutilisation souvent elles ont
été dévolues à d'autres d'autres
activités donc c'est c'est un sujet qui
est important sur les ptge qui est un
sujet également que nous souhaitons
suivre avec attention puisque il y a une
démarche là qui peut paraître vertueuse
mais on peut s'inquiéter parfois des
délais le renforcement des pouvoirs des
préfets ce qui nous intéresse aussi
c'est de savoir s'il y a un système
d'évaluation aujourd'hui qui a été mis
en place sur le cadencement et les états
d'avancement qui nous permet de trait
d'avoir un reporting peut-être aussi
plus efficace de la capacité que ces
projets pourraient avoir effectivement à
ce de réaliser et puis d'une manière
plus générale au travers des questions
que l'on a pu vous poser ce qui nous
intéresse particulièrement au travers de
votre expérience et donc quelque part
des premiers retours que vous pouvez
aussi analyser c'est en perspective mon
toile de fond de la loi accélération sur
les énergies renouvelables c'est il y a
sans doute depuis que les conclusions du
varen ont été rendues des éléments qui
aujourd'hui mériteraient de travailler
pour aller plus vite plus fort et il
faut regarder aujourd'hui comment nous
pourrions avancer sachant bien sûr que
ces travaux
résonneront plus particulièrement avec
les annonces du ministre de chute nous
attendons sans doute dans la semaine ou
dans les jours qui viennent et on
essaiera de mettre tous ces sujets en
résonance voilà c'est le préfet
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
peut-être commencer par un très bref
rappel sur sur le varen le varen s'est
déroulé de mai 2001
j'ai toujours
donc le varen s'est déroulé de
mai 2021 et a été conclu le premier
février 2022
ça a consistait une large consultation à
la fois de structure et de personnes
et les conclusions du varen
s'articule autour de ce qu'on appelle
trois thématiques ou trois piliers
le premier pilier c'est la protection de
l'agriculture face au changement
climatique avec la réforme essentielle
de l'assurance récolte qui est gérée par
une direction générale du ministère de
l'Agriculture un deuxième pilier qui est
l'adaptation au changement climatique je
pourrais revenir un peu plus dans le
détail si ça vous intéresse et donc un
troisième pilier qui est l'accès
raisonné à la ressource là où c'est
possible et je crois que c'est important
de retenir c'est que le varen c'est
vraiment cet équilibre entre
l'adaptation et l'accès à la ressource
c'est pas l'un contre l'autre c'est pas
l'un ou l'autre c'est vraiment les deux
ensemble avec une modulation à avoir
selon les réalités territoriales
[Musique]
ça s'entend
je vais tenté de poursuivre si vous si
vous m'entendez parce que j'ai pas une
voix de chanteur d'opéra
pour venir aux questions que vous avez
posées monsieur de sénateur d'abord sur
l'inventaire des des plans d'eau
existants c'est une des mesures
effectivement du varen la maille qui a
été retenue c'est d'inventorier les
plans d'eau de plus d'une superficie
supérieure à 0,1 nectar et ça c'est fait
par un système de photographie depuis
satellite
l'inventaire a été fait
nous arrivons sur le plan national à un
volume d'environ 350 000 plans d'eau
existants donc c'est une masse
considérable d'informations
et il y a actuellement un travail qui
est fait par l'Inspection générale de
l'environnement du développement durable
sur la méthode d'utilisation et
d'échanges avec les territoires de toute
cette information parce que
ce qu'a permis
l'inventaire c'est cette connaissance
fine de l'existant
le système photographique permet aussi
une évaluation du volume des réserves
modulo l'envacement qui peut y avoir
bien entendu
il permet aussi de voir le marnage des
réserves ce qui est un indicateur est-ce
qu'elles sont utilisées ou pas
et si on veut aller plus loin
ce dont on a besoin de
de connaître c'est la propriété du
réservoir à qui appartient
quel est l'état des installations est-ce
qu'il y a des exploitations agricoles à
proximité intéressée pour recevoir de
l'eau
et comment on organise la relation entre
le propriétaire du plan d'eau s'il est
s'il est encore connu parce qu'on va
tomber sur des situations où ça sera
plus le cas et les bénéficiaires de
cette ressource donc c'est tout ce
travail qui est en train d'être fait
actuellement mais il est clair qu'on a
des marges de manœuvre importante à
retrouver par la remobilisation du
patrimoine hydraulique existant je ne
parle même pas du patrimoine de voies
navigables de France
voie navigable de France et de plus en
plus un transporteur d'eau d'irrigation
en complément de son activité navigation
fluviale
tout le sujet de l'état du patrimoine
ce qui nous intéresse dans le travail
aujourd'hui qui est lancé autour de
cette inventaire
autour de cette inventaire
c'est d'arriver à discerner en termes de
temporalité quand nous pourrons
optimiser ou commencer à optimiser
effectivement ces ressources parce que
l'exposé que vous avez fait nous laisse
à penser qu'il y a quand même encore
devant nous
un temps relativement important pour
qu'on puisse éventuellement rentrer dans
une démarche vraiment opérationnelle
il y a sans doute aussi un certain
nombre de de ces réserves qui vont être
discutées dans la aspect contributive
sur le plan écologique
on a bien vu donc dans leur propriété
privée de quelle manière on pourra
passer aussi des accords pour pouvoir
mobiliser ces masses d'eau c'est un
élément qui est important parce que
si on pense arriver à optimiser
véritablement ses ressources d'ici par
exemple 5 ou 6 ans ça nous permet de
clarifier un peu la capacité de pouvoir
les utiliser
alors on a commencé ce travail
d'optimisation ça s'est fait à peu près
concomitamment avec le varen quand ont
été mobilisés des crédits du plan de
relance pour l'hydraulique agricole et
nous sommes en train de terminer
dans le cadre du ministère de
l'Agriculture ce qu'on appelle la revue
de projets d'hydraulique agricole
c'est-à-dire région par région on fait
un point de de situation
en distinguant les projets qui seront
prêts au mois de juin prochain
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont contribuer à
passer la prochaine saison d'été et les
projets de de plus long terme
ce qui a été
recensé
ce sont 164 projets d'hydraulique donc
44 seront finalisés d'ici la fin juin
2023 alors
des projets représentent 37 millions de
mètres cubes au total
sur ces 37 millions de mètres cubes il y
a 5 millions de mètres cubes de volume
supplémentaires et donc le reste mais je
n'ai pas la répartition c'est à la fois
de la substitution et de la
réhabilitation
d'ouvrages existants je vous cite un
exemple c'est un tronçon du canal
latéral à la Garonne qui est en
Tarn-et-Garonne que VNF est en train de
restaurer actuellement et bien entendu
l'enjeu ça va être de poursuivre ce
travail
on a également
lancé une une expérimentation c'était en
avril de l'an passé sur trois
départements du Sud-Ouest le Gers le
tarn-et-gar le gère c'est sur trois
projets le Tarn-et-Garonne et le lot
il y a eu toute une série de contraintes
à prendre en compte
ces départements ont subi le gel au
printemps dernier donc sur les projets
individuels il y a la règle des minimis
qui s'est
qui sait qui s'est imposé il faut aussi
jouer au mieux avec les régimes
autorisation déclaration et la durée de
validité des crédits du plan de relance
il y a un autre sujet qu'on a identifié
qui est celui du statut des bouts de
curage
puisque elles sont considérées comme des
déchets et
lorsque la retenue est en travers d'un
cours d'eau le seuil de
d'autorisation est à 2000 mètres cubes
ce qui est relativement bas
donc au total sur le Lot et de
Tarn-et-Garonne dans chacun de ces
départements il y a 15 à 20 projets qui
sont sortis le Gers a eu une approche un
peu différente de beaucoup plus ciblée
ils ont sorti trois projets évidemment
on va se nourrir de cette
expérimentation pour en tirer des
enseignements
recenser les recenser les 350 000 plans
d'eau nous on a un autre problème dans
le département et autour tout ce qui est
Sologne
ou la DDT est en train de faire la
chasse tous les étangs de Sologne qui
n'ont pas qui ne sont pas dans les dans
les règles soit pour les faire assécher
ou pour les reboucher donc vous voyez il
y a des contradictions aussi
où l'administration parfois essaye de
supprimer des plans d'eau existants sous
prétexte que ils ont pas eu toutes les
autorisations à une époque et ça c'est
un sujet aussi que
avec le problème de l'évaporation nous
dit que faut supprimer un certain nombre
de plan d'eau parce qu'il y a trop
d'évaporation sur certains territoires
remarque complémentaire par rapport en
reprenant l'exemple que vous étiez du
terme du Gers des expérimentations qui
sont menées du coup là je suppose que
l'Agence de l'eau est directement
impliquée aujourd'hui sur ces sujets là
ce qui se dégage aussi sur certaines
pistes c'est le fait de conforter bien
sûr la gestion par bassin mais au-delà
de cette confrontation d'aller vers un
référentiel de plus en plus clair entre
la disponibilité de l'eau à l'échelle
d'un comité de bassin et les
consommations d'eau à l'échelle d'un
comité de bassin c'est à dire qu'on est
bien aujourd'hui un système qui nous
permette de mesurer à la fois la
capacité la ressource mais en même temps
les niveaux de consommation pour essayer
d'ajuster au mieux en fonction
effectivement des usages et donc ça peut
constituer une forme de référentiel de
connaissance qui mérite d'être le plus
fin possible et le plus approfondie
possible est-ce que ce sont des sujets
que vous avez également abordés dans le
cas de du varen sur la connaissance et
la gestion optimisée de la ressource
c'est un sujet qui apparaît au travers
de ce qu'on appelle les volumes
prélevables
vous avez vu que la réglementation a
évolué l'été dernier puisque jusqu'à
présent raisonné sur les volumes
prélevables en période d'étiage il y a
un décret qui a été publié fin juillet
2022 pour définir la notion de volume
prélevables or la période de basseaux
l'idée sous-jacente derrière c'est de
pouvoir prélever quand l'eau est aband
est abondante pour pouvoir stocker en
prévision des des périodes de sécheresse
ce texte doit s'appuyer sur une
méthodologie de définition des volumes
prélevables et une étude a été confiée à
l'inrae et à l'OSB pour définir cette
méthodologie d'études est en cours
il y a un sujet sur lequel on doit se
voir d'ici quelques jours avec les deux
organismes c'est capables dans le bassin
Rhône Méditerranée on n'a pas forcément
des chroniques des prélèvements sur
l'ensemble du territoire peut-être aussi
parce qu'on prélevait pas ou très peu en
dehors de des périodes de
sécheresse donc là il faut voir comment
on fait évoluer cette étude pour pour
avoir des résultats je suis absolument
pas scientifique mais je me dis qu'on
peut peut-être tester l'idée de partir
d'une méthode plus expérimentale
empirique on sélectionne
un échantillon de de territoire on teste
on voit ce qui se passe et on essaie
d'en tirer des
[Musique]
enseignements plus plus généreux mais ça
tout ça sous le contrôle des des
organismes plus qualifiés que moi pour
pour se prononcer
peut-être à ce stade on a certainement
des questions à Catherine Loisier avait
demandé la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Préfet en fait moi je voulais orienter
un petit peu la discussion sur la
stratégie de lutte contre les incendies
de Touareg puisque nous avons aussi en
parallèle un travail au sein de cette
assemblée et que la capacité à mobiliser
les ressources en nous les plans d'eau
en fait existants notamment dans les
massifs forestiers
et de plus en plus souligné par les
différents acteurs et notamment les
pompiers pour pouvoir intervenir
rapidement donc je voulais savoir si
cette question était appréhendée en fait
dans votre analyse et
comment est-ce que ça s'organise à ce
que c'est partagé aussi avec les les
services d'incendie et de secours
alors le sujet de la lutte contre
l'incendie ou la défense de la forêt
contre un contre l'incendie n'est pas
dans le périmètre du varen qui est
vraiment sur la ressource en eau pour
pour l'agriculture
on appréhende pas le fait que si on dit
sur sur les massifs concernés on va
devoir aller quand même prélever de
l'eau dans les points d'eau ça fait
partie de des points à voir dans dans
l'étude de méthodologie
puisque de toute façon dans les textes
en période de sécheresse il y a deux
priorités qui sont fixées c'est
l'alimentation d'eau potable et c'est la
défense contre contre l'incendie donc
c'est un des paramètres autre élément
on se rend compte que dans la
constitution des des réserves
autant il peut y avoir des discussions
très fortes sur les réserves
spécialisées autant dès qu'on est sur du
multi-usages
tout le monde au fond s'y retrouve un
peu
et par exemple j'avais visité au mois de
juillet dernier
tout près de Dijon une réserve qui a été
constituée en bordure d'une zone
d'activité qui récupère les eaux
pluviales et dont la vocation est de
gérer un épisode de pluie je puisse être
décennale
des plus extraordinaires
le réservoir réalimente le cours d'eau
qui est proche le réservoir fourni des
maraîchers qui sont dans le secteur et
évidemment
s'il y avait un moment ou un autre un
problème sur la zone d'activité c'est
une formidable réserve d'incendie
ce type de démarche et d'intéressant
donc pour vous répondre le sujet reste
entier le sujet incendie n'est pas dans
dans mes compétences mais il est dans le
paysage
mais peut-être juste par rapport à notre
collègue ce dont on s'aperçoit c'est que
les quand il y a eu des sinistres et des
incendies importants il y a eu
d'ailleurs un appui conséquent des
agriculteurs
justement pour être sur des zones
d'appui et puis essayer de limiter la
propagation du feu ou être effectivement
en surveillance donc c'est juste pour
mémoire mais l'intérêt c'est qu'il y ait
une interaction qui soit faite en termes
à la fois de recensement des ressources
du fait que les ressources soient aussi
bien situées en termes d'aménagement du
territoire pour améliorer le maillage en
termes de protection des incendies au
delà de ce qu'on peut prélever sur les
circuits d'eau potable et les bâches qui
peuvent exister et donc voilà il y a
aussi cette réflexion si cette réflexion
peut participer en plus d'un écosystème
qui le cas échéant pourrait amener des
multi-usages pertinents tant mieux mais
c'est il faut pas le perdre de vue il
faut le poser sur la table parce que
c'est aussi aujourd'hui
des enjeux relativement importants on va
dire en termes voilà d'aménagement aussi
du territoire et d'organisation
de l'implantation de l'ensemble de ces
ressources
vient de soulever Catherine c'est que en
Sologne on rebouche éventuellement des
des étangs là il y a un non-sens parce
que en Sologne il peut y avoir aussi des
incendies donc
je peux pas rester exactement ils font
la chasse aux retenu
il soit vraiment dans les cas alors que
bon une époque en faisait des retenues
sans il y avait pas besoin de demandes
il y a des dizaines d'années c'était un
peu compliqué
elle pose de sérieux problème après
c'est moi je vais peut-être qu'on peut
regarder aussi le pourquoi et le
positionnement de la DDT aujourd'hui sur
ce sujet là
il faut les interroger je voulais juste
pour finir de demander à Monsieur préfet
qu'est-ce que comment qu'est-ce qu'il
préconisait parce que on voit bien qu'il
y a quand même une urgence de se pencher
sur la ressource enfin sur la
disponibilité en cas de cette ressource
pour la lutte contre les incendies qui
qui risque d'être massive étendue
géographiquement donc un une vraie c'est
pas une considération accessoire quoi ça
va forcément impacter les plans d'eau et
la ressource en eau dans les mois à
venir qu'est-ce que vous nous conseillez
comme approche de ce sujet parce que là
ce que vous me dites c'est que vous vous
ne l'appréhendez pas donc qui à votre
connaissance l'appréhende et à quel
moment en fait ce font les les
conjonctions quoi parce que si on va on
est obligé d'aller puiser dans les
ressources d'eau donc elle mesure on va
faire des arbitrages par rapport à l'eau
potable enfin je voilà comment comment
cette conjonction cette coordination
peut se faire
je vous livre une expérience
personnelle j'aurais tendance à dire
déjà ça se fait sur le terrain
notamment
lorsque on travaille sur les sur les
plans de secours et les 10 connaissent
bien quand même l'implantation des des
ressources possibles
que tout le monde enfin si tu peux
perdre tous nos jours aujourd'hui c'est
de partager des connaissances sur les
massifs français parce qu'il faut savoir
les dessins sauf dans les sauf dans le
Sud où il y a des prix ou des choses
comme ça mais dans le reste du
territoire où il n'y a pas de de
document de DFCI qui connaissent pas
c'est je pense que c'est en train
d'évoluer là aussi je vous cite un
exemple totalement personnel
j'habite à Fontainebleau je sais qu'en
forêt de Fontainebleau il y a une
politique qui est partagée entre
le 10 de Seine-et-Marne et l'ONF qui le
gestionnaire de la forêt pour implanter
des des citernes alors les citernes
permettent pas de tenir sur un sinistre
complet mais à l'attaque du feu ça
permet d'éviter à peu près de noria de
camion donc d'être plus efficace
je pense que la direction générale de la
sécurité civile doit être très
mob ilisé sur le sur le sujet je me
souviens de l'intervention il y a
quelques temps du directeur adjoint
qui disait que pour l'éveil armée de
de Canadair et sur les stations de
remplissage des des avions
la géographie était en train de remonter
au nord et vers l'Est de la France parce
que le risque s'accroît
[Musique]
oui merci beaucoup de ces éléments de
ces éclairages peut-être une remarque
sur les réserves d'eau et peut-être
certaines qu'on ne qu'on n'a pas recensé
moi un exemple très factuel dans ma
commune on avait un réservoir qui
existait avant l'adduction en eau
potable que tout le monde a un peu
oublié finalement parce qu'il ne servait
plus à rien il y a sans doute des
travaux à faire dedans mais ce sont des
volumes importants qui ne sont pas à
l'heure actuelle recensées qui ne sont
connues de personnes qui mériteraient
sans doute de la réhabilitation on y a
réfléchi mais pour l'instant peu d'aide
encore son péché là dessus donc je pense
qu'il y a vraiment déjà un travail de
recensement de voilà de réserves d'eau
qui peuvent exister qui peuvent être
utilisés pour l'incendie parce que c'est
c'est près d'une forêt et je pense qu'on
manque de connaissances sur cet aspect
là qui pourrait peut-être une petite
partie de la solution et de voir comment
accompagner les collectivités pour
réhabiliter ses réserves
merci merci Monsieur le Préfet et chers
collègues je voudrais je voudrais savoir
si il y a aujourd'hui un lieu
interministériel où on
conforte finalement votre travail autour
du Varenne agricole de l'eau le travail
sur la lutte incendie et celui sur les
enjeux de évidemment de l'alimentation
d'abord mais de la biodiversité
également et deuxième question vous
évoquez le recensement des réserves en
eau un certain nombre sont dans des
zones humides avec j'imagine des
nécessités de préservation donc est-ce
que derrière sur enceintoursement il y a
une classification des
usages possibles de ces réserves ou bien
une façon de les sortir certaines
doivent être réservées pour l'incendie
d'autres doivent être préservés pour les
milieux naturels donc est-ce qu'il y a
une classification sur ce sujet et j'ai
en profite pour une troisième question
combien de ces réserves sont alimentées
par prélèvement dans les nappes
phréatiques
[Musique]
alors
tout d'abord sur notre organisation
nous n'avons pas souhaité que la
création de la délégation
ajoute des structures administratives au
structures administratives donc la
délégation s'insère dans les travaux du
Comité national de l'eau dans les
travaux du comité d'anticipation et de
suivi hydrologiques dans les instances
nationales de gouvernance de la
politique de l'eau
ce que nous avons créé c'est un comité
de pilotage du varen
dans lequel sont présents
sont présentes pardon toutes les
administrations concernées par la mise
en oeuvre des 24 mesures
dans lesquelles sont présents les
présidents des différentes thématiques
du
varen
et donc c'est
lors de ce comité de pilotage qui est
présidé par les deux cabinets du
misériculture et de la secrétaire d'État
à l'écologie que l'échange
interministériel
se fait nous avons tenu un premier
comité de pilotage au mois de novembre
le second a eu lieu en janvier et le
prochain aura lieu à la fin du printemps
enfin très probablement au début du mois
de juin
voilà voilà comment se fait de la
coordination un petit peu
institutionnelle
[Musique]
pour ce qui est de la classification des
des usages possibles de l'inventaire
c'est le travail qui est en train de
réaliser des jeux DDD et c'est là dessus
qu'on a besoin
de mettre en place une méthode d'échange
avec les territoires
parce que la connaissance sera locale
c'est pas sur une base de données de 350
000 plants d'eau qu'on peut qu'on peut
le savoir
il peut y avoir deux hypothèses c'est
soit
travailler avec le réseau territorial de
l'État je pense aux directions
départementales des territoires
ça peut être aussi de travailler avec
les étapes les établissements publics
territoriaux de bassin les EPTB donc ça
c'est il y en a pas partout
effectivement c'est ce qu'il faut
vraiment préconiser il faut interroger
aussi du fait les sages je pense que si
on veut bien
repérer l'ensemble des parties prenantes
susceptibles d'apporter ses informations
aussi les EPCI en charge de la gemapi
parce qu'ils ont aussi une assez bonne
connaissance de leur environnement et
ils peuvent être susceptibles également
d'être pouvoir ailleurs d'informations
mais ça suppose qu'il y a une forme
d'enquête qui soit structurée et
cohérente sur l'ensemble du territoire
et Monsieur préfet je suis pas sûr que
ça soit le cas à l'heure actuelle
je suis pas certain je crois qu'il
faudrait parce que la remarque de notre
collègue est tout à fait pertinente ça
nous permettrait pour le coup d'affiner
véritablement au travers des différents
usages ou des différentes possibilités
la nature enfin les champs du possible
c'est vrai que c'est le fait de pouvoir
faire une forme de classification de
référentiel à ce niveau là ou de la
fumer c'est vrai que c'est ça serait une
excellente chose
peut-être que c'est un sujet que vous
allez peut-être approfondir
quant à l'origine la ressource en eau
de ces réservoirs là je n'ai pas les
éléments mais
j'imagine quand même qu'on a beaucoup de
patrimoine historiques relativement
anciens et qu'on est beaucoup sur de la
captation de ressources en cours d'eau
mais je peux pas vous dire il y a telle
part et tel part parce que je n'ai pas
la donner
excusez-moi vous ne connaissez pas le
nom
de zone de captation dans les nappes
pour l'irrigation
ça doit être recensé quand même non le
nombre national
[Musique]
non moi je ne le connais pas mais je
sais pas si la direction
vous avez dans le varen de l'eau il y a
eu 24 annonces à peu près qui ont été
est-ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il y a un
ordre de priorité est-ce que
certains de ces annonces ont été mises
en application ça c'est la première
question et la deuxième tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé de de réserve
multi-usage
et dans nos auditions on s'aperçoit que
finalement c'est peut-être pas la bonne
solution parce que c'est difficile de de
que ça soit compatible entre le
l'irrigation
les loisirs la pêche ou autre et donc
quelle est la position où votre position
dans le varen de l'eau concernant les
réserves pour l'agriculture est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux avoir des réserves
spécifiques
ou est-ce qu'on peut arriver à faire du
visage avec toutes les difficultés que
je viens de vous citer
clairement le multi-usage peut poser la
question du partage de leurs sources je
ne dis pas le contraire
[Musique]
j'aurais tendance à ne pas en faire une
question doctrine et vraiment à faire du
travail au cas par cas sur sur les
territoires c'est un peu toute la
logique de la politique de l'eau une
politique décentralisée une politique
partenariale c'est vrai que dans
certains secteurs on peut avoir
plutôt
une tendance à des équipements
d'exploitation individuelle de petites
tailles répondant aux besoins de
l'exploitation en particulier
pour être sûr du collectif ou du
multi-usage
il faut des équipements plus grands ça
veut dire qu'il faut un maître d'ouvrage
aussi et ça c'est un sujet il faut cette
mis d'accord sur la répartition de la
ressource c'est pour ça que je pense
vraiment que c'est du cas par cas
sur les sur les 24 mesures
alors
sur
sur les priorités bon on a 24 mesures on
a que 24 mesures donc on peut avancer
quand même
relativement de façon homogène
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que sur
les 24 mesures on en a 23 qui ont
commencé à être mis en oeuvre on pourra
revenir un peu plus dans le détail si
vous le souhaitez pour ce qui est des
financements
nous avons
des crédits du plan de relance 2022 pour
de l'hydraulique agricole c'est 45
millions d'euros
qui ont été en intégralité
utilisée et un complément cette année
qui est de 20 millions d'euros après le
varen
[Musique]
fait référence à toute une série de
crédits liée à France 2030 et ces
crédits sont en train d'être mis en
place à pas soit par des appels
manifestes sur Internet soit par des
appels à projet
je peux cite vous citer par exemple
l'appel à projet qu'on appelle troisième
révolution agricole qui est gérée par
France agrimaire 20 millions d'euros ont
été mis en place en 2022 mis en place et
utiliser
pour cette année ce sont 40 millions
d'euros qui viennent d'être mis en place
juste peut-être si vous me le permettez
sur sur ce sujet là qui touche aussi les
politiques d'accompagnement à
l'efficacité à la sobriété
donc on a aussi des interrogations
récurrentes sur
la capacité la qualité aussi en termes
de recherche appliquée pour monter aussi
à la fois en compétence et améliorer les
matériels pour que on aille vers on
puisse remplir effectivement ces
objectifs
la problématique qui est posée bien sûr
c'est la notion d'accessibilité
économique du modèle économique
acceptable pour la filière et les
agriculteurs puisque ils ont sans doute
envie de le faire mais sous quelles
conditions aussi économique donc ça
c'est un sujet qui est prégnant et dans
les sujets que vous évoquez
s'interroge et interroge également la
contractualisation notamment avec les
conseils régionaux puisque dans le cas
du développement économique et de la
Recherche et de l'accompagnement des
filières il peut avoir des compétences
aussi spécifiques et donc dans quelle
mesure les crédits que vous avancez ou
du moins une partie sont contractualisés
pour accompagner au mieux les acteurs
France 2030 c'est une gestion
qui a qui a sa propre logique puisque on
est derrière
avec le secrétaire général pour les
investissements
cela étant les projets qui sont
présentés les gros projets sont
articulés voire contractualisés avec les
collectivités locales joue cite un
exemple on a un appel à projet qui
s'appelle démonstrateur territoriaux
sur lequel on a de lauréat qui sont en
lien avec le varen
le premier c'est la chambre journal
d'agriculture des Pays de la Loire sur
toute une série de mesures d'innovation
en agriculture et donc de gestion
efficiente de de l'eau
le second c'est un dispositif de
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées
dans le sud de l'Hérault et le sud du
Gard pour
irriguer de la viticulture il est clair
que ça se fait avec l'opérateur qui fait
le traitement des eaux et donc les
collectivités qui sont intervenantes sur
sur ce sujet ce projet s'appelle salto
sa LT apostrophe
est-ce que vous avez aussi des
informations particulières à nous donner
sur ce sujet et puis on a abordé la
question de la sobriété est-ce que vous
avez des sujets complémentaires que vous
pourriez vous indiquer oui alors sur la
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées
on a parfois tendance à agglomérer
beaucoup de choses un petit peu
différentes
on a la réutilisation
à défend ou d'irrigation ou
d'utilisation comme comme des eaux
brutes on a aussi un sujet plus
particulier qui est celui de la
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées en
milieu d'industrie alimentaire
qui est
tiens un sujet en soi
je parle même pas de la récupération
des des eaux pluviales des autres
toitures qui est l'un des sujets qui est
en train d'être exploré assez
vigoureusement en Bretagne
mais aussi en Franche-Comté
plusieurs types de réalité
différente
ce qui est en cours c'est la mise au
point
d'un décret et d'en arrêter c'est un
couple juridique qui vous me permettait
ce que beaucoup que beaucoup attendent
donc sur la réutilisation des eaux
usées traitées en milieu industriel
l'idée étant de définir des couples
entre
les précautions
sanitaire et de sécurité alimentaire et
l'utilisation de l'eau
pour schématiser plus on se rapproche de
la production alimentaire elle-même plus
évidemment il faut avoir des des
standards élevés donc le décret sera un
décret en Conseil d'État l'arrêter
interviendra après avis de l'entesses et
l'objectif est d'y arriver le plus
rapidement possible
pas à ce stade mais
parce que on peut comprendre que la
France soit un pays particulièrement
précautionneux mais du coup il y a quand
même
des expériences et des pays européens
qui sont beaucoup plus engagés sur ces
sur ces sujets là
j'imagine qu'ils ont dû comme nous se
poser les mêmes types de questions donc
on est quand même pour le coup parce
qu'on peut-être qu'il y avait pas la
pression si forte on est quand même très
en de ça de de pratique de certains pays
donc on commence aujourd'hui un peu à
s'étonner des résistances
juridiques et administratives un peu sur
le sujet
de consommation qui nous reviennent
après de ces pays-là qui utilisent les
eaux
les choses sont en train d'évoluer
il est vrai que nos partenaires
européens sur la base et même texte
européen font différemment donc il y a
il y a des choses à explorer et
notamment par le beaucoup de la Belgique
qui est
en avance alors après sur la
réutilisation des eaux usées traitées il
y a quand même un certain nombre de
filtres à prendre en compte
premier filtre
ne pas oublier que les autres sorties
des stations d'épuration en perte des
tirage concours à l'alimentation du du
débit desiages
deuxième filtre c'est un filtre
sanitaire enfin même ça devrait être le
premier c'est
de s'assurer que l'eau réutilisait et
vraiment
aux normes attendues
il y a un filtre
économique le coût du traitement et du
traitement éventuellement supplémentaire
tout à fait
y compris actuellement le coût de
l'énergie pour pousser l'eau dans les
dans les canalisations
et puis pour les industries alimentaires
je pense qu'il y a aussi une approche
commerciale par rapport par rapport aux
risques
donc être sûr que
la réutilisation soit faite dans des
dans des conditions optimales du point
de vue du consommateur et de du point de
vue sanitaire
ça
sera pas une solution miracle mais c'est
une solution
les industries laitières me disaient que
il pourrait être en capacité de
récupérer jusqu'à 15 millions de mètres
cubes
par an avec les autres récupérer du
séchage du lait pour en faire de la
poudre on les a rencontrés ils ont dû
vous le dire donc
on a besoin nous on a aujourd'hui besoin
effectivement d'y voir un petit peu plus
clair sur les perspectives le
développement des expérimentations et
clarifier un peu aussi des objectifs du
gouvernement en la matière il y a un
sujet aussi
qui est quand même particulièrement
important et transversale aussi dans vos
interventions les interventions des
collègues nous-mêmes notamment quand on
parle des volumes prélevables en hiver
ou des retenues de rétention
le principe étant de travailler
l'acceptabilité des projets pour dire on
peut remplir effectivement des
ressources quand on a une eau qu'on ne
pourra pas capitaliser au niveau de
l'environnement au contraire si c'est
eau va lessiver des sols de fait de la
brutalité des précipitations etc on peut
aller vers une forme de gestion
vertueuse qui permet de stocker l'eau
quand le milieu on a moins besoin et que
les précipitations sont très importantes
pour restituer ensuite ces taux à bon
escient si possible dans une
un petit paysage si cela est possible
donc ça ce sujet là effectivement est un
sujet de fond reste à avoir
comment clarifier la connaissance sur
comment stocker à vos décisions
comment
améliorer la prise de décision ou la
gestion optimale de la ressource
c'est-à-dire le stockage à bon escient
pour pouvoir également le restituer à
bon escient ça c'est un sujet de fond
parce que quelque part les volumes
prélevables en hiver vont concourir
aussi à créer de la ressource en eau
pour la pouvoir la redistribuer sur
d'autres cycles saisonniers on est bien
d'accord
est-ce que c'est un sujet qui a été
vraiment posé
au niveau du varen de l'eau comment la
profondeur
parce que dans tous les débats que nous
aurons sur ce sujet là avec l'ensemble
des partis prenantes les associations
environnementales etc c'est une donnée
fondamentale
d'estimer et de caler ce qu'on peut
arriver à pouvoir stocker sans que ce
stockage n'est d'incidence trop forte
par rapport à l'ensemble du
milieu ce que le sujet a été posé de
façon approfondie dans les débats du
varen je n'étais pas là au moment du du
varen j'imagine qu'il a été évoqué je
suis pas sûr que
il y a eu une
approche comment dire Bruxelles
holistique
c'est clairement un sujet qui est dans
le périmètre de l'étude au FB d'accord
technique
les mètres cubes ont qu'on prélève il y
a aussi toute la dimension humaine et
sociale comment
on gère tout ceci on la compagne pour
avoir l'acceptabilité sociale parce que
le sujet derrière c'est celui là
je pense que c'est un sujet très
important très important
il est assez déterminant après même sur
des prises de décision sur des ptge etc
c'est des éléments de connaissances
ou de monter en connaissance qui sont
vraiment vraiment essentielles
je pense que c'est juste un mot Hervé si
tu permets bon il y a un stockage par
les nappes phréatiques d'une grande
partie et en fait un des sujets moi qui
me qui m'intéresse c'est de se demander
les externalités positives et les
externalités négatives de chacun des
modes de stockage version si on en
choisit un stockage entre guillemets
artificiels
en période hivernale pour une
réutilisation en période estivale s'il
n'y a pas d'externalité négative il
faudrait être stupide pour s'y opposé en
revanche si ça se traduit par une
diminution des nappes un assèchement des
sols et du coup une exigence plus grande
d'irrigation de ce serait à l'inverse
stupide d'aller prélever des ressources
alors que par le stockage naturel dans
l'ENAP et par l'humidification des sols
ils permettent une résilience plus
grande y compris pour les activités
agricoles
il y a un élément dans le varen sur
lequel j'ai
je n'ai pas insisté
c'est cette idée que le sol
et le meilleur stocker d'eau qui qui
existe d'où tout ce qui concerne
l'infiltration de l'eau dans le dans le
sol
il y a aussi un sujet qui est peut-être
pas assez exploré c'est l'articulation
entre les plantes prévention des
inondations les zones d'expansion des
crues
et l'infiltration
j'ai vu que dans vos dans votre séance
d'installation vous évoquiez scène grand
lacs et l'établissement public
a un projet en ce sens
à la confluence de l'Yonne et de et de
la scène la stratégie d'infiltration
elle est fondamentale on l'a indiqué
aussi de manière récurrente sur
l'inscription
la gestion du fil de haut le document
d'urbanisme et qu'aujourd'hui il faut
qu'il appréhension aussi dans les
scottes dans les pluies parce que c'est
un facteur qui peut être assez
déterminant pour améliorer la gestion du
fil de l'eau et notamment la
reconstitution ou la meilleure gestion
des zones humides il vaut mieux que le
pluvial aille vers des zones humides
qu'il aille vers du réseau qui voilà ce
que je veux dire et c'est un élément qui
est aussi très important parce que si on
est dans une politique cohérente pour le
coup on améliore la gestion globale et
on améliore aussi ce que vous venez de
dire le stockage au niveau des sols
en agriculture il y a tout il y a aussi
tout le sujet du travail des sols
l'apport de matière organique qui
favorise le stockage les couverts
végétaux par exemple
la lavande des cultures dans le sud et
est en train de regarder donc on voit
toujours les champs de la vente là c'est
c'est grandes raies avec de la terre
nuit autour mais comment avoir un
couvert végétal entre deux rangs pour
mieux gérer la situation en eau alors
tous ces ce qu'on appelle les leviers
d'adaptation c'est un travail qui est
dont le chef de fil et Lacta lakta c'est
la Fédération des instituts techniques
des filières et ils travaillent en
articulation avec l'inrae et Chambre
d'Agriculture France c'est l'un des
éléments sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique dans le varen et du coup dans
ces gestion on va dire vertueuse pour
améliorer la résilience aussi et la
capacité stockage des sols le couplage
avec les politiques agricoles et les
politiques européennes
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
dans le cas des travaux du du varen de
l'eau comment optimiser aussi les fonds
européens en la matière est-ce que vous
avez des éléments de données
alors sur les fonds européens on est
clairement sur le sujet articulation
avec les régions puisqu'elles sont
devenues autorité de gestion et que le
la nouvelle génération de Pâques
va se développer à partir de ce de ce
printemps et donc par rapport aux
mesures au catalogue de mesures
nationales les régions ont décidé de
prendre ou ne pas prendre telle ou tel
voler et il y a des volets qui qui
concernent
l'irrigation
sur
l'articulation
pack
varen politique de l'hydraulique on a un
élément important qui est par des mots
c'est un peu technique ce qu'on appelle
l'article 74 du règlement fait Ader qui
encadre les
aides aux investissements
hydrauliques et notamment qui
les proscrits ou les limites dans les
zones où
les masses d'eau sont qualifiés en état
moins que bon donc il y a cette volonté
de cohérence j'irai au plan européen
entre sur la France ça va être compliqué
la Pâques et le
et la directive cadre sur l'eau après
tout l'enjeu c'est la cartographie des
de ces zones
des agences de l'eau c'est des comités
de bassin et puis des différents acteurs
par rapport à ça parce que pour le coup
le non-respect de la DCE sur un certain
nombre va donc impacter directement la
capacité de l'Europe à intervenir on est
bien d'accord
que
c'est un sujet en termes de mobilisation
de politique des moyens
donc nous on aura une audition avec les
associations de collectivités il faudra
pas qu'on perde de vue de questionner à
ce niveau là parce que c'est quand je
vous parlais de la contractualisation
tout à l'heure ça ça en fait partie
puisque là ça passe par le Comité des
Régions et par les régions on est bien
d'accord sur cette négociation avec les
fonds européens
c'est un sujet
un sujet important
on a évoqué monsieur préfet un certain
nombre de sujets à ce stade est-ce que
vous souhaitez peut-être nous apporter
des éléments là qui nous pourraient nous
être particulièrement utile que nous
n'aurions pas abordé
ma feuille de route
il y a un sujet qu'on n'a pas abordé qui
est important parce qu'il immobilise
beaucoup il y a beaucoup d'enjeux
ce sont les travaux des filières
agricoles sur leur plan d'adaptation au
changement climatique
en utilisant là aussi toute une série de
[Musique]
levier
on a
11 familles de filières qui travaillent
en fait elles y sont toutes mais
certaines sont regroupées par exemple
dans des grandes cultures il y a toute
une série de de filières différentes
cette d'entre elles en sont au plan
d'action
le plan d'action
est souvent orienté sur
la question de l'efficience de
l'irrigation et d'une irrigation économe
en ressources mais il n'y a pas que ça
il y a tout l'aspect adaptation variété
etc donc ça c'est un gros travail qui se
fait qui se fait rapidement qui est
supervisé si je puis dire par par France
agrimaire qui a fait une petite
publication au moment du savon de
l'agriculture sur l'avancement de ces
travaux
en complément la délégation
demander
le déroulement d'une mission du Conseil
Général de l'agriculture d'alimentation
et des espaces rurales CGR
sur ce qu'on appelle la notion de
production résiliente
on a connaissance saella
d'expérimentation de nouvelles
productions pour s'adapter au changement
climatique
quelques exemples le miscanthus comme
culture
énergie le lin le chanvre le sorgho donc
ce qu'on cherche à faire avec ce travail
c'est
capitaliser au plan national
[Musique]
d'évaluation qu'on peut faire de ces
expériences
pour pouvoir commencer à se dire
sur telle culture ça vaut vraiment la
peine de
d'insister tel autre et moins
prometteuse c'est pour se donner une
grille de lecture
sachant qu'il y a la dimension
agronomique
qu'est-ce qui se pose qu'est-ce qui
pousse pas il y a la dimension
économique pour l'exploitation et puis
il faut regarder deux autres choses
c'est les filières industriels de
transformation
et la demande du marché
parce que s'il y a pas de demande du
marché
je crois que on pourra faire toutes les
expériences qu'on que l'on voudra voilà
donc ça c'est un des éléments forts avec
le travail des filières sur l'adaptation
monsieur
sur cette question de l'adaptation qui
est une question effectivement très très
importante et finalement jusqu'à présent
on traitait assez peu les les comment se
fait le travail au fond c'est un travail
pragmatique par par retour d'expérience
sur sur des choix de culture sur des
types mais quel est l'objectif parce que
récemment le ministre Béchu annonce
ce qui paraît assez réaliste pour
beaucoup de scientifiques depuis
longtemps une France a plus 4 degrés
et évidemment la France a plus 4 degrés
avec des baisses des niveaux des tiages
à 20 ou 30%
la question de l'adaptation
permet pas de la même façon que dans une
France a plus un ennemi ou plus de
degrés et des niveaux d'étiages qui
diminuent plus faiblement donc comment
fait-on parce que par exemple vous
évoquez la question de la demande
sociale sur sur les céréales ou sur
d'autres d'autres sujets cette demande
il faut sans doute aussi peut-être la
stimuler enfin voilà c'est que peut-être
si on a pas une capacité d'adaptation
suffisante de toute façon on aura une
obligation d'adaptation plus brutale si
elle n'est pas anticipée c'est ça ma
question c'est comment faire pour que
l'adaptation soit une vraie adaptation
et pas une adaptation au moment où on
arrive dans le mur et au fond qui aura
une grande brutalité avec des risques
d'effondrement de de filière agricole
entière
c'est dans cette logique d'anticipation
que ces travaux ont été lancés des à
présent et c'est vrai que sur ce sujet
du changement climatique
on a un contexte d'ensemble ou le
changement climatique s'accélère et il
va presque plus vite que nous donc là on
a on a vraiment une question de de
rythme
par rapport
à l'activité agricole
là aussi on va travailler sur une
multitude de de facteurs les produits
comment on adapte et jusqu'où les
productions actuelles au changement
climatique par exemple dans l'élevage
les animaux sont extrêmement sensibles à
la question de la de l'élévation de la
température alors après les
interventions c'est du travail sur le
bâtiment terre d'élevage peut-être sur
la façon dont on gère le fait de les
amener à la prairie ou de les de les
mettre à l'abri enfin c'est de la
pratique professionnelle quotidienne
après on a
des changements de culture alors dont
certains se font assez spontanément pour
l'été 2022 alors c'est peut-être pas que
le changement climatiquement pas que ça
mais on a bien vu qu'il y a eu une
substitution maïs oléagineux
avec très certainement l'incitation du
marché
à ce moment là et puis il y a le
troisième stade c'est
quel type de culture
ou adaptée aux nouvelles c'est
tout tout le sujet variétal et quelle
géographie des cultures
dans le haut de France
on dit qu'il y a une céréalisation de
l'agriculture c'est la culture des
céréales qui remonte vers vers le nord
c'est quand même un grand changement
sur d'autres filières c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué
en viticulture
je vois mal
comment on peut voir les choses
autrement que ce lien entre la
production et un territoire parce que
c'est c'est intimement lié donc voilà
c'est c'est un travail sur beaucoup de
beaucoup de facteurs et le prolongement
c'est une initiative qui est en train de
finir de paramétrer Chambre
d'Agriculture France avec le réseau des
Chambres c'est un dispositif
d'accompagnement
des exploitations dans l'adaptation au
changement climatique parce qu'on sait
que ça prend du temps que c'est lourd
c'est que c'est difficile
aujourd'hui disent que plus ça va plus
leur politique vont aller sur du soutien
d'investissement et non pas fonctionnant
donc comment finance aussi l'ingénierie
d'accompagnement au changement
climatique c'est un peu ça des questions
qui se posent aujourd'hui
là-dessus on a à partir de 2022
mobilisé les fonds du plan national de
de recherche du ministère de
l'Agriculture le PNDA r
16 projets ont été retenus pour un
montant de 5,9 millions d'euros et dans
ces projets il y a beaucoup de
recherches sur l'adaptation varietale
mais
c'est vrai que le sujet c'est de trouver
d'identifier des leviers de changement
d'identifier comment on fait et après
ça va se jouer au plus près de chaque
exploitation et là on a besoin de cet
accompagnement
[Musique]
c'est un sujet qui est important
moi je reviens juste sur des éléments
que l'on a abordé déjà
sur le fait que
[Musique]
il y a aujourd'hui véritablement une
nécessité d'améliorer la
contractualisation entre les moyens de
l'État le moyen notamment des régions
avec le réseau alors on parlait des
champs de consulaires mais des chambres
d'agriculture sur aussi des politiques
d'accompagnement d'accompagnement aussi
au changement et de monter
qualitatif des process on va dire de
production d'une manière générale et on
a du mal à discerner voyez-vous
aujourd'hui au travers même des échanges
et des auditions ces clés de lecture
c'est de qualité ou cette prospective en
termes de contractualisation qui
permettrait de créer les effets leviers
et de créer les conditions d'un meilleur
accompagnement en termes de moyens
notamment sur l'adaptation au changement
on a du mal c'est compliqué c'est pas
clair
en tout cas un sujet
et les régions sont aujourd'hui des
acteurs majeurs
sur ces sujets là
et vous nous en parlez peu
dans notre revue de projet notre tour de
France des régions
on voit bien en implication des conseils
régionaux
on va en Occitanie
en PACA bénéficie d'outils particuliers
il y a tout le système du Rance Verdon
il y a le canal de Provence
mais il y a une vraie dynamique on a
tous les projets sur sans retenue sur
Over une Rhône-Alpes qui sont bien
relayés avec la région sur Bourgogne
Franche-Comté j'ai vu qu'il y avait un
appel à projet adaptation changement
climatique la stratégie des
orientations la région Bretagne est
aussi elle-même très très présente je
disais sur la récupération des eaux de
toitures
vous nous citer aussi
avec les politiques de l'État
après ça se fait
au niveau d'administration territoire de
l'État
madame latrix vous avez une
question comme mon collègue brûlé sur le
sujet ça me permet de rebondir sur sur
la question en effet la coordination
avec les services de l'État relativement
politique régionale vous citez au Père
Ronal pour ces retenues je pense que
c'est en effet une forme de vision qu'on
a de répondre à la crise mais vous
l'avez très bien dit ça peut pas être la
seule vision faire des retenues ça passe
vraiment vers une transition
culturelle de pratique il faut
accompagner les agriculteurs et si on
les accompagne seulement dans un sens en
disant on va vous faire des retenues on
peut continuer comme avant le problème
c'est que ça ne marche pas donc c'est
vraiment essentiel que y compris il y a
un pilotage de l'État sur une
coordination avec l'État sur les
politiques régionales pour qu'on marche
bien sur nos deux pieds me permettre en
effet de l'irrigation qui est
indispensable mais aller vers des
transitions agriculturales pour
s'adapter pour aller vers des moyens de
de production qui préservent les sols
qui préservent leur infiltration ça
c'est vraiment indispensable donc
voilà vous dites que vous êtes en train
de commencer à recenser des pratiques
qui sont vertueuses mais moi je pense
qu'il faut aujourd'hui aller très vite
parce que le changement climatique va
très vite et il faudrait pas qu'on
investisse massivement
dans des dans une partie de la solution
et pas dans l'autre partie de la
solution qui est aussi la transition
culturelle sur laquelle il faut
j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus accompagner
les agriculteurs parce qu'à un moment
donné créer des réserves ne suffira plus
il se trouveront eux-mêmes en difficulté
donc c'est vraiment important de marcher
sur ces deux pieds et que l'État il
contribue totalement
vous avez repris une expression que
j'emploie souvent le varen marche sur
ces deux pieds l'adaptation et l'accès à
la ressource là où c'est possible je
vous rejoins complètement
bien avez-vous de la question sinon on
va vous
et
c'est vrai que tout à l'heure je ne sais
plus qui a dit dans le mais c'est vous
peut-être bien Monsieur le Préfet dans
le Nord on fait des céréales et il y a
eu un inversement qui s'est fait chez
moi on fait des pommes de terre
maintenant vous voyez et les pommes de
terre chez moi et ça demande énormément
d'eau donc c'est un peu un non sens et
là tous les agriculteurs dans le secteur
ceux qui avaient un peu de moyens ils se
sont tous mis mais engouffrer dans ce
dans cette culture et il va y avoir un
problème c'est sûr
en plus
c'est monté à côté des usines des usines
de transformation mais mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas logique avec les terres
que nous avons c'est la Champagne
pouilleuse qu'on appelait donc je peux
vous dire que c'est de la terre qui est
pas du tout du tout
faites riche voilà merci donc c'est un
problème c'est vraiment un problème mais
les pauvres ils ont fait ce qu'on leur
demandait aussi
bien
merci Monsieur le Préfet
de votre éclairage et puis merci à mes
collègues
d'avoir participé à cette audition très
difficile c'est moi qui vous remercie
bonne suite de travaux
c'est moi qui vous remercie bonne suite
de travaux